is the key to birth okay and it's
oxytocin oxytocin is literally the queen
of the hormones oxytocin is the hormone
that is released during intimacy social
interactions uh sex orgasms oxytocin is
this beautiful incredible hormone quite
shy but extremely powerful this hormone
is the same hormone that drives labor
when you first start to feel those
surges which are manageable at the start
of your labor this is a perfect time to
celebrate and it's the perfect time to
really party through the first stage of
your labor and get the music on that you
love you know dance move all this
movement and dancing and mixed with
oxytocin is gold dust it is setting you
up for a really incredible birth
experience I talk about imagining you
know if you wanted to get intimate with
the person that you love you wouldn't go
outside into the front guard Garden
invite your neighbors to watch like
everyone come in we're gonna have sex
now it's you know you'd be dry as a bone
and it's exactly the same when we
Implement that that really sort of Love
Making intimate time and we actually
take that and then put it into birth
that is why you you can then experience
something which a lot of people call
orgasmic birth which could mean
completely euphoric and pleasurable in a
different sense or it could mean
orgasmic is in an actual feeling of an
orgasm
that was Emma Armstrong a mother
certified Doula Hypno birthing
practitioner and birth influencer
residing in the UK founder of the naked
Doula which you need to be following on
Instagram by the way she's a speaker
worldwide and helps women transform
their birth experiences with practical
and emotional tools educating women to
make the best informed decision that is
right for them she made a prominent
appearance in the birthing Community
when she began inspiring women with her
Unique Style and witty and surprising
language after being inspired by her
late mother who passed away during her
pregnancy her translation and
explanation of birth has impacted
thousands in their search for a positive
informed and empowered birth experience
this episode was so much fun for me not
only because I love talking about birth
and it's one of my favorite topics but
also because at the time of this
recording I am due to give birth in just
two weeks so it's making me extra
excited I just really love birth you
guys so you can find find Emma on her
Instagram at the naked Doula and her
website as well for the wealth of
knowledge and educational content that
she shares without further Ado welcome
to the elementary podcast enjoy the
episode
all right welcome Emma to the podcast I
am so excited for this conversation as
you know I'm due to give birth in a
couple weeks right now as we're
recording this so all the more reason to
have this conversation because I love
all the encouragement all the tips like
going into each birth is just so
exciting to me so for people who don't
know who you are can you kind of share
your story what led you first to
becoming so passionate about helping
women have an empowered and
transformative birth experience yeah for
sure so I I've always been interested in
childbirth
um for quite some time and I've always
been interested in Midwifery but I just
never got there and it's it's kind of
strange when I look back now because I
think there is a reason for that I
always sort of got that step further to
go into you need to do Midwifery but it
just never worked out
um and then three over three years ago
when I was pregnant with my first
Charlie
um I had a really tough pregnancy
and not in myself I felt absolutely fine
but Charlie
um Charlie was breech I had my mum who
was
um unfortunately
um diagnosed with cancer and she was you
know sort of end of life
so she passed away around
she passed away around 26 weeks of me
being pregnant
and I
I think I at that point I hadn't really
focused much I realized I hadn't really
focused much on on the pregnancy or the
birth and even though I was passionate
about those things and I'd been doing a
bit of hypnobirthing I I sort of just
took this grief
and just started pushing it into like
this Focus but it came like a bit of an
obsession as you can imagine
um from that happening and I just was so
focused on on birth and childbirth and
learning everything about it and the
more that I learned the more that I
realized that everything that we all
know from growing up and learning about
birth is is very untrue there's lots of
um on learning that needs to be done for
that
um and then I ended up having an
absolutely euphoric birth and it was a
C-section which was completely the
opposite to what I intended to what I
wanted I wanted a home birth I wanted
all natural
um but he was extremely stuck and I had
a C-section and I influenced that
massively I had the most euphoric
incredible C-section and just from that
point I
just sort of found this power inside of
me to really want to educate and to to
work with other people and that's what
sparked me to do my training and to
start working with people and it just
it's just gone gone crazy ever since and
I'm more obsessed than ever so I am
absolutely so excited for this
conversation
yeah I love this conversation about
birth and firstly I'm so sorry about the
passing of your mom I can't even imagine
going through that while you're pregnant
something so traumatic and hard to go
through and experience while you're
trying to you know take care of yourself
and prepare for birth that must have
been incredibly difficult and I think
it's so beautiful the way you're
speaking about your birth that's
something that I think is really
attractive to what you're sharing
because you're sharing so much about
making educated and informed decisions
and
being what's right for you and to to be
able to say I had a euphoric C-section I
think is quite a stigma something that a
lot of people don't talk about and I
think it's really beautiful to be able
to frame and reframe essentially that
birth can be beautiful no matter which
direction it heads up in it goes in even
if it's not what your original plan was
and so I think that that's what I want
to like really get into more right now
about like how you are helping people to
take harness of their power and learn
their different options and do what's
right for them because one of the things
I really love to say a lot is that women
should be giving birth wherever they
feel safest like wherever you are safest
that's where you should be giving birth
exactly
exactly do you know what I'm so glad you
said that because this is the whole
point you know if if home doesn't feel
good for you then home is not the place
to give birth for you like there's no
right or wrong way and there's no
one-size-fits-all for birth you know and
this is why we really have to tap into
our inner power so we can make these
decisions that are best for us so I just
love that because that's exactly exactly
hit the nail on the head to what I talk
about most you know
right so can you kind of elaborate a
little bit more by what you mean about
how you had a euphoric C-section what
does that look like can you just explain
that for people yeah sure so literally
people are always gobsmacked because
a lot of people think oh as soon as they
know they're having a c-section whether
that's elective or emergency they think
that's it all their options are out the
window but that's really not the case we
have so many options when it comes to
actually being in theater
um from what we can ask for what we can
work with our
um with our caregiver for example dimmed
lighting music essential oils I had I
had essential oils around me I had like
my music playing I had my mom's hand
print like you know I felt like I was
just in my bedroom I'd like my hand
print next to me and you know and it was
just and they dimmed the lights and I'd
literally had asked for skin to skin
straight away I asked them to deliver
the placenta at the same time so that I
could get optimal cord clamping for my
baby and when I was actually in theater
I've been practicing hypnobirthing and
this is
when you understand how you can
influence your oxytocin how you can
influence your body no matter how you're
giving birth that's going to make a
massive difference and I just zoned out
I was in a beautiful place it was so
like out of body experience I was
sitting on a bank with my mom we were
holding hands
and we were just enjoying the rip
honestly it was insane and then all of a
sudden I heard Adam and my partner he
sort of did a bit of a gasp
and I open my eyes and baby was was
gently gently coming out and straight
onto my skin and he was so calm
he was so calm and they they were a bit
like oh you know but I knew because you
know you know you're you know your body
you know your baby and I just I knew he
was he was happy he was calm because I
just had a very calming birth experience
and this is where it makes a massive
difference because it doesn't matter
which path it takes if you understand
the basics of how to influence
your birth through using those hormones
and going into those places and
surrendering to birth however that looks
then you can have the same experience no
matter what
that's amazing that the way you explain
that words are so powerful I think and
when we speak life into people's stories
it helps other people like Into Your Own
Story it helps other people to be able
to speak life into their own story so
maybe somebody listening has had a
C-section and might have have traumas
behind it right and being able to hear
someone else's story about it could
bring a little bit of Peace about it I
think or at least help women going into
the future that if they do need a
C-section that there are ways to
influence how you are feeling around
that C-section 100 you know and I think
a lot of the time we feel like having a
c-section means we're a complete failure
and our body cannot birth and you know
and I think this is where like a lot of
the trauma comes from but it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean that that at all
every birth is valid you know that
doesn't mean that you know I'm a failure
or I'm you know worse off than the
person that you know I mean obviously
physiological differences of course you
know there are physiological differences
is we that's science but at the end of
the day the experience you can still
have that experience and anyone I just
say to anyone that has had that
C-section and feels that way you are so
valid and your birth is so valid it
doesn't you know make you any different
to anyone else and I think when we go
back and we we go like sort of go
through our stories retell our stories
in our minds we can really help to
regulate our nervous system really help
to regulate those emotions and really
feel good and happy about you know what
happened
yes totally I just launched a birth
course called the empowered pregnancy
and birth that I worked so hard on these
last months and I've never been more
proud of something I've created this
course is filled with everything I wish
I was told before I came pregnant with
my first child over a decade ago to have
an easier quicker labor and even a
pleasurable birth experience and we're
doing a huge price promotion right now
now through October 9th for 100 off the
course just click the link in the
description box or show notes and enter
the code launch party at checkout this
is the first and only time we'll be
offering a price promotion this big so
even if you're not pregnant but you
think you'll want to use this resource
in the future now is the time to get it
and take advantage I created the course
with my sister Hannah McNeely and we
have some incredible contributors in
this course including Dr Gemma Newman
who collaborated with us on plant Ford
prenatal nourishment she's an MD who's a
senior partner at a family medical
practice that has worked in many
Specialties including obstetrics
Gynecology and Pediatrics we have Haley
Callahan a donor certified Doula who
collaborated with us on having an
empowered birth for those choosing a
hospital setting we also have an
incredible yoga instructor Michelle
Minch with prenatal yoga classes in
birth meditation and finally Heather
McCain on the Mind change method and how
to rewire your brain for a more
pleasurable and gentle birth experience
which is one of the most powerful parts
of the course in my opinion because
something like Hypno birthing for
example can be really helpful for a lot
of women women but for many women like
myself you can say all the positive
mantras you want out loud and envision
the birth you desire but if your
subconscious believes otherwise and
tells you uh-uh that's not what birth
feels like I know what the movie showed
me it feels like I know what my mom and
friends say it feels like I know what my
past birth experiences even felt like
then it's not going to get you very far
that's why we have to rewire our brain
and change not only the conscious mind
but also the subconscious mind and
Heather someone who's helped so many
women like myself achieve the birthday
desire shows you in this course how to
do that this course is centered around
becoming empowered and making informed
choices optimal pregnancy nourishment
giving birth where you feel safest
getting back to birthing wisdom and my
favorite part how to have an easy quick
and pleasurable birth experience it's
filled with how to prepare your mind and
body for conception creating a birth
plan that's right for you we also go
into nutrients of focus healthy foods to
embrace and supporting your body through
movement how to to get baby in the
optimal position for birth and the
secrets to avoid tearing how to have an
easier labor guaranteed and the
information that made my last three
labors significantly more pleasurable
gentle quick and easy than my first two
we include everything you need to know
postpartum breastfeeding and more and
there's even a lesson for your partner
if you have one in how they can best
support mama in pregnancy labor birth
and postpartum so you can get access to
the course at ellenfischer.com or click
the link in the show notes and
description box to learn more about the
course I've never been more proud and
excited about something I've created
birth is life-changing and I'm really
passionate about sharing all that birth
can be gentle peaceful easy and even
pleasurable so don't forget to enter the
code launch party at checkout for 100
off and it ends October 9th so can you
get into a little bit speaking of like
educating yourself or being able to make
informed decisions
what the red flags are for if you're
with a practitioner practitioner or a
hospital or healthcare provider or even
Midwife things that are red flags for
you to be aware of when you're coming to
making your own informed decision of
course so you know wherever you are in
the world
um you know especially obviously in
America
um I think maybe same in Hawaii uh you
know it's medical insurance isn't it so
you are paying for a your care provider
here in the UK we have
um that care as standard
um anyway but never nevertheless
whichever route that is wherever you are
in the world that care is there to
support you to help advise you it's not
a law
and that's really important for people
to know you know what what we are being
told is not law it is giving us
information uh for us to go away educate
ourselves and make informed decisions
so for example red flags for me and I
hear this a lot
um a lot around induction because I hear
things like you we have to induce you at
40 weeks otherwise your baby may die you
know really terrible terrible things
that that women are being told oh you
know your placenta is going to fail if
you go over this amount of weeks
um don't put yourself in danger so I say
anything that anything that you'll have
if you're having conversation and a
comment comes across from a place of
like fear like it's fear driven or it
sounds cohesive that is a red flag that
is a red flag that is time to stop and
just say hang on a minute
can you explain this more to me can you
provide me with the evidence can you
back this sort of Statistics because
a lot of the time we are so frightened
to actually come forward and ask for
that but it's our Birthright it's our
human right and our Birthright and
that's your birth you know maybe you
have one two three you know and in some
cases if five babies but each time it's
a incredible experience that you need to
be able to make the best decisions for
so those for me are red flags you know
or when they want to try and do
something without your consent for
example a sweep
I'm just going to do a bit of sweet or I
did a sweep whilst I was down there
that is disgusting that is assault and
battery like no one shouldn't
yeah can you explain what a sleep is for
someone who doesn't know of course so a
sweep is where you would have a vagina
it would be like a vaginal examination
the Midwife would pop their fingers up
and they would sweep around the cervix
this is to try and stimulate the labor
process okay but what a lot of people
don't know is that if your baby and body
are not ready
and this is a form of induction which
they they don't necessarily tell you all
the time but if your body and baby are
not ready that is not going to do
absolutely nothing at all it's just
going to irritate the cervix you may
experience bleeding
um you may experience very you know
uncomfortable feelings some people say
it's very painful
um and
it could be absolutely just make no
difference at all some people there's a
50 50 chance for those whose bodies and
babies are ready it can sometimes you
know stimulate the labor process
but for a lot of people it can just be
done right and comfortable and this
happens this is happening that's been
done without people's consent all the
time
so it's important to know that and
understand these things and ensure you
know what your care provider is doing
and why they're doing it yes absolutely
I love what you said about being willing
to confront someone's statements towards
you to to challenge it if it doesn't
feel right some people I think really
struggle with confrontation and so it
can be difficult to do that but
harnessing like your power going back to
that and talking about the importance of
this being your birth and like you said
your Birthright to have informed
decisions I think is so important to be
able to respond back to something that
doesn't make sense and I think it's
really helpful to encourage that because
a lot of times we're just kind of told
okay this person knows more than me I
have to just listen to whatever they say
and not challenge it but that's not
necessarily the case no and a lot of the
time we have this White Coat Syndrome
you know we go into a hospital or
doctors and straight away we're sitting
on a bed or sitting on a chair and we're
sort of okay and that's very natural
that's a very natural reaction to that
environment but birth is not a medical
issue
birth is not a medical problem that you
need you know help with it's not like
you've broken your leg and you need to
go and be asking the questions about why
they're putting a cast on your leg you
know it's it's completely different
birth is
um birth is happening and it's happened
for for you know
it's
hundreds of thousands of years you know
it's been going on for so long it
doesn't need is to be rigid about it it
needs us to just get in that get within
ourselves find that power
and that comes that comes with time and
that comes with learning and education
and knowledge and being able to then
bring that forward and ask the right
questions
perfect so let's get in are there any
more red flags that you want to mention
or should we get into my next question
yeah there are a few of the red flags
which which I find uh really frustrating
which is the suspected big baby
so a suspected big big baby is something
that comes up a lot we think you we need
to induce you or we are going to induce
you because you've got a big baby
um just to be clear for everyone out
there when it comes to growth scans
later on in pregnancy they are
notoriously inaccurate
you cannot possibly measure
the size of a baby who is curled up
inside of your womb all nice and tight
and snug it's almost impossible to
measure that also our bodies are also
different so you might have a small bump
you might have a big bump you might have
a a different kind of bump like that's
completely normal and that's fine
there's no again there's no one size
fits all
um and a suspected big baby is not a
reason to induce
it is not and that I hear it often very
scary you know that the big baby due
dates
kind of thing going on a lot of the time
and it's just it's just completely
unnecessary so get informed
absolutely I do have a friend who had
that experience and she was very she
felt left very defeated by it and um
pretty much traumatized from it because
she was told and scared into an
induction saying your baby is so big
your baby's likely 10 pounds we have to
we have to induce you or it's not going
to be possible for you to give birth
vaginally and so she got the induction
and her baby came out six pounds and
just she was so frustrated by that
because she really she didn't want to be
induced and so that is something that's
really helpful for people to take into
consideration like knowing the facts
behind it how difficult it is for them
to really measure that and sometimes the
inclination that Physicians can have to
induce even if it's unnecessary 100 and
you can birth a 10 pound baby like yeah
you know unless unless you have a
medical condition which is going to you
know in your heart on steroids is going
to affect the size of your baby which is
you know through drugs for example any
nor like normal low-risk pregnancy if
your baby's growing your uterus will
only grow as much as your body can grow
you know so most of the time your body's
not going to give you a baby that you're
not capable of birthing
you know we lose confidence in our
bodies but our bodies are incredible and
they know they know how to birth
right so what's one more red flag and
then I want to get into my next question
which I'm excited about brought to you
today by bite I'm obsessed with bite
toothpaste bits for so many reasons not
only do you avoid the harsh chemicals
artificial flavors and preservatives
that you get from conventional
toothpaste you also get to avoid the
plastic waste from using bottled
toothpaste as well that's why bite makes
toothpaste tablets made of clean
ingredients that are sulfate palm oil
and glycerin free and on top of that the
jars are so pretty it comes in
refillable glass jars and they send
refills and compostable pouches so
they're better for our bodies and our
Earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it will turn into
Pace just like you're used to but with
no plastic tube or messy paste which
makes it extra convenient for kids who
think popping a bite in their mouth is
so fun and makes toothbrushing time a
pleasant experience it honestly felt a
little weird at first but now my whole
family is obsessed it's so effective and
makes my teeth extremely clean I ran out
of bite to toothpaste fits once so I
went back to my old regular toothpaste
and very quickly I realized that my
teeth didn't feel as clean so I'm never
going back to paste and we'll be using
bite from here on out and my holistic
dentist fully approves bite makes
plastic free alternatives for everything
on your bathroom sink so you can cut out
the harsh chemicals and plastic waste
without compromise and bite is offering
my listeners 20 off your first order go
to trybite.com Ellen or use the code
Ellen at checkout to claim this deal
that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e.com slash Ellen I will
just touch on I'll touch on due dates
because
due dates come up a lot we are all given
an estimated due date and it always
seems to be if you don't if you're not
sort of ready to give birth on your due
date or your baby doesn't come that is a
dangerous situation and we need to get
you in straight away
um and then a lot of coercion starts
around that date just to be clear due
dates are extremely inaccurate and they
are based on a rule that was made up by
a man in 1744 based on
like 300 Dutch women
that is it and this rule this rule from
1744 we are still using today to try and
calculate birth what makes this even
worse is that because they didn't know
whether he meant seven day you know
seven days
you know at the end of the end of the uh
period or at the start of the period you
know it wasn't clear
the American American Medical School
decided that it was actually the start
of the period so they knocked it back at
an extra week
oh wow yeah so so in most places it's
it's 40 weeks but and I'll just say this
now so I I'm expecting I'm expecting a
baby as we spoke about and my
congratulations thank you thank you and
my my actual sort of you know gestation
at the moment is six and a half weeks
which is untrue because I I know my date
of conception so I'm only four and a
half weeks theoretically
but I'd be classes six and a half weeks
so imagine I then go and I continue on
and they said this is your due date I
get to 40 weeks but I know my baby has a
couple more weeks left in in him or her
you know before they may be ready to be
born it's it's so different only four
percent of babies are born on due dates
please don't get hung up on it and you
know really ask the questions trust your
body and do your research
perfect yes that's such good advice to
not because it's easy to get so hung up
on a date when really it could be many
different days surrounding that okay so
my next question is like something I'm
so excited to get into what are your top
birth tips as a doula as an educator
that people need to know for an easier
and more pleasurable labor
do you know what this this is so super
simple so super simple and it is the key
to birth okay and it's oxytocin
oxytocin is literally the Queen the
queen of the hormones oxytocin is the
hormone that is released during intimacy
social interactions uh sex orgasms
oxytocin is this beautiful incredible
hormone quite shy but extremely powerful
so this hormone is the same hormone that
drives labor that is what is signaling
your uterus to contract
so with more oxytocin that's flowing in
our body the more that our beautiful
uterus this beautiful group of muscles
are able to contract and really give
optimal
um contractions and optimal dilation
along with this the more oxytocin we
have flowing the more euphoric we feel
the more in tune the more you know sort
of in touch with ourselves some people
really feel that euphoric feeling and
then you have I mean I love it because
then oxytocin signals endorphins okay if
you can imagine endorphins they come
down on parachutes like the SAS they
attach themselves to the nerve receptors
the end of the nerve receptors and block
pain signals
your your body has a beautiful Network
and a beautiful way of of creating a
beautiful pleasurable enjoyable birth
experience which feels intense of course
but at the same time powerful
and that's the difference between
understanding that and how to influence
those hormones compared to going in with
fear and actually having adrenaline
to take away all those hormones scare
them all away and being completely rigid
and that's where all the pain comes from
right that's where all the tenseness and
this this whole horrible feeling of
course it's going to hurt you know your
body is pushing against the muscle like
that's tiring and that's painful you
know yeah so my absolute Ultimate key to
that experience is oxytocin and you can
go as as far as you want with that you
can go as far as you want with that if
you want to introduce you know nipple
stimulation you know that intimacy and
the you know clitoral stimulation even I
mean that literally is like
the gold of creating the best possible
labor and the best possible contractions
you know
I know I know and this this is what gets
me the most excited about birth because
this is for anyone listening who doesn't
know this is going to be my fifth home
birth that I'm having and in my first
two births my midwives I remember I was
you know going through the motions it
was taking a long time it's dragging out
my midwives they both different midwives
were different births said why don't you
go be intimate with your partner go go
be alone and be intimate and I looked at
them like they were crazy I'm like what
are you talking about no way that is the
last thing I want to do right now
because I hadn't Associated sex and
birth to being connected and to the
feelings of pleasure being connected
with birth the way that sex is so
suffice it to say I ignored their advice
and my labors were 24 and 26 hours long
and just dragged on and I didn't I
didn't associate that pleasure sensory
experience with sex like I did with
birth so then with the third birth I
really wanted it to be different than
this time I was like I'm gonna do is
this differently and I did a lot of
subconscious work retraining my brain
um with what is called the Mind change
method with a friend of mine who is a
practitioner with that method and I was
like I want this labor to be eight hours
long I want it to be pleasurable and I
want it to feel good and we used words
that were much more associated with like
pleasurable sensual feelings and then
once I came into labor I found myself
actually wanting to be intimate with my
partner because I had really understood
at this point how they're connected and
what a difference it made like my whole
body softening and and for anyone
listening as you're explaining this
you're explaining oxytocin and sensual
pleasure I've seen you explain it before
on your Instagram
um and also this is a way I love to talk
about it as well is like if you're
having sex and you're not happy safe
secure and loving it sex does not feel
good like that's not what sex is
supposed to feel like like and you're
tense or or if somebody walked in on you
while you're having sex like everything
just clamps up right like as opposed to
when you're alone safe and secure and
you have all the connective feelings
with sex like sex is pleasurable you
soften you open up and everything feels
better and that's exactly what happened
in my birth it was amazing I love that
and this is it a lot of people that feel
the same as you did in your first two
births say like that is just in their
mind they can't comprehend that it's
kind of like oh why would I be feeling
that way in my labor but actually they
are so closely connected because it is
the same hormone and when you understand
that and you're right I talk about
imagine you know if you wanted to get
intimate with with the person that you
love you know and you end up you
wouldn't go outside into the front
garden invite your neighbors to watch
and you know and then Brian down the
road we're going to get him to tell your
partner if he's a man you know when to
push
like or go to the hospital and be like
everybody watch yeah exactly like
everyone come in we're gonna have sex
now it's you know you'd be dry as a bone
he you know he would be just shriveled
up you know like within himself it'd be
so embarrassing and it's exactly the
same when we Implement that that really
sort of Love Making intimate time and we
actually take that and then put it into
birth
that is why that is why you you can then
experience something which you know a
lot of people call orgasmic birth which
could mean completely euphoric and
pleasurable in a different sense or it
could mean orgasmic is in an actual
feeling of an orgasm
um and I mean and I mean I'm sorry but
like why wouldn't you not want to you
know feel that pleasure like I cannot
wait to give birth I literally have told
Adam like you better be ready for this
because it's gonna be it's gonna be a
um a very you know intimate birth
experience this is because it works like
a dream dilation it does dilation you
will dilation just happens so fast
because your contractions are just so
beautifully optimized and your body's
soft like you're saying it's just easy
it just opens like a like a flower it's
just insane it really does yes and it
all it's open and soft and even with my
fourth birth I went into it and took it
a step further where the language that I
was using was very sexual and sensual in
my brain and what I and so it was very
everything was about plump juicy soft
opening expanding you know and all that
like by actually really focusing on it
not just like hearing it and not
believing it but actually believing it
to be true and experiencing it through
intimacy with my partner by letting him
take care of me in those beginning
stages like that just made me so much
softer and more open that literally
birth happened in like five hours like
it just it just happened so fast because
you're actually soft and open whereas
when you're tense rigid and like you
said Dry is about like everything just
holds in and takes longer yeah it's not
any memo any mammal in the wild you know
they go to a safe place they go
somewhere they feel safe mostly on their
own and they labor but any sign of
danger close by their body will
instantly make sure that that baby is
not coming so you can imagine all these
people that are scared that worried that
are surrounded by eyes and have their
legs wide open and they feel
uncomfortable you know and we're saying
you're not progressing you're not
progressing you're not progressing
blaming it on the woman
which is disgusting when actually it's
nothing to do with them at all it's to
do with the environment is to do with
how they're feeling and
this is why it you know progression
takes you know a long time or it just
stops all together because we are
literally sucking the life out of these
women you know and and putting them in a
position where their bodies are going no
[ __ ] way you know yeah and actually I
think that's really important to bring
up about the feelings that you're
feeling because you can have all the
Ambiance set up you can have the
essential oils you can have the dim
lighting which is all really helpful but
if at the end of the day you're feeling
scared tense
um nervous unsure all these things and
you're feeling kind of like a spotlight
on you like that it's the feelings
that's really going to create the
outcome of your birth and a lot of times
we kind of think that where these
passive passengers in birth and we have
no control over helping the outcome in
any way and obviously there's certain
circumstances which are completely
happenstance and out of our control but
a lot of it we can influence through how
we are feeling and so it's what this is
why we have to get to that place and
that's why a lot of people talk about
Ambience because it helps you get to
that safe feeling but if you have that
Ambiance and you're still failing this
way like something else is is going on
inside and that is what needs to be
looked into exactly it has to be
addressed you know we could we could use
all the tips in the world you know for
our environment but if we haven't
tackled you know um the references that
are in our brain then you know it's not
going to be helpful I always say to
people if you can imagine you're
um your brain like this this brain
Library the hippocampus part of the
brain where all the references are
emotions everything is stored
inside of there you have references for
everything riding a bike making a cup of
tea you know how we act and you know
everything like that when we see
something we recognize that's a tree or
whatever so in there's also about birth
we've gone through our childhood hearing
about birth watching Hollywood movies
you know listening to other people's
stories so the only references we have
in our brain by the time we get pregnant
as a person who doesn't really know
about birth all we then know is really
basic shitty information and scenes that
we've seen on TV which are completely
dramatized so if we don't then actually
look at that and start putting in things
and start working on our reference
system then that's why most of the time
you go in and instantly your body goes
into this
survival mode because it has it doesn't
know it doesn't know what to reference
it to all it knows is these negative
things
and that's why working on that part of
the brain is is so important and it's
not like a an overnight thing you know
it takes work just like anything you
want something to you want to influence
something you want to do really well at
something it takes time and effort you
know it's not like I'm just gonna wing
it and hope hope I hope it goes well
like the dream job interview I'm just
not going to prepare I'm just going to
wing it and hope that I get the job
you're going to prepare and you're going
to make sure that you know your stuff
and it's exactly the same with birth
yes and that's why people anybody
listening who's interested in birth
who's pregnant or gonna be pregnant or
know someone is pregnant should go
follow you on Instagram the naked Doula
because you share so much information
that's basically rewiring the brain of
what all the stuff we've been taught our
whole life because like you said those
images those videos they're Wheeling the
women and rushing everyone's screaming
the woman's screaming and it's like
hurry get her to the Tigger rush her to
the delivery room like the moment the
first contraction is like all that stuff
needs to be rewired because it's in your
subconscious that we've been seeing our
whole lives and so once you retrain even
just the way you explained your euphoric
C-section that is imprinting into our
brain an idea and a thought of what
could be and all that's all of it plays
a role into how we view bird exactly 100
and you know what the page is designed
to help sink into your brain it's really
you know that's that's the way it's
designed those images and that really
basic information mixed with the visuals
is why people can just be scrolling
through for you know a few weeks and all
of a sudden they start to feel this
change and this difference in how they
they feel towards birth and it's
incredible it's absolutely incredible
and if that's what it takes you know you
just gotta start somewhere
perfect okay so let's so we tackled the
sex and birth relation what's another
top tip people need to know about birth
the one of my one of my ultimate
ultimate top tips is about your soft
face your face your jaw because
you know you might think that you're
relaxing your body but a lot of time we
hold tension in our jaw and our Jaws are
connected to our pelvic floor so if you
can imagine if we are tense in our face
if we are texturing a contraction in our
face or for example
um the pushing stage of Labor if we're
tense our pelvic floor is very tight
so we are then giving our YouTubers less
room
so it's going to find it really
difficult to contract we're really going
to feel that and on the pushing stage
we're really going to just make
everything very tight down there so it's
going to be very difficult for our baby
to come down the birth canal and be born
in a gentle way that we want them to be
born so I call it floppy face floppy
Fanny now I know in the US Fanny means
bum bottom but I know I'm looking at I'm
like yeah love it I'm not referring to
the bottom I'm referring to your vagina
okay I'm referring to your vagina in the
UK we we sometimes call the vagina Fanny
and this is what I'm referring to if you
have a floppy face you're allowing your
your vagina to be relaxed as well and
that whole area and that is literally
gold when you're when you're moving
through your contractions uh when you
feel that intensity Rising just even
repeating that Mantra floppy face off
your fanny floppy face funny really
concentrating on dropping this face and
then when you get to the peak thinking
oh my God this is like the most amazing
optimal time of my contraction really
sort of Leaning into that
literally every single person that I
work with and every single story I get
from around the world every single one
of them has floppy face floppy Fanny
Mantra in it because it is gold
yes I so agree I with my first birth I
did Hypno babies like a hypnobirthing
class and while it was helpful I think I
was missing the mark either be
maybe it was from the way that I
received it or the way that it was
explained to me wasn't as helpful for me
but when I went to birth as I was going
through labor I remember listening to
the woman on the tape and I said this
Hypno birthing thing is [ __ ] because
like I wasn't it wasn't working for me
whatever was imputing but what I
realized after I had multiple births and
seeing what was happening I had was
relaxing my shoulders I was relaxing my
body I was going to those positions that
felt the most comfortable but I was
hiding and retreating from the place
that your the intention of the relaxing
is to relax the pelvis area relax the
vagina relax that area but I was trying
to do that just by retreating from it
and finding the most comfortable
positions I could find which would slow
down labor as opposed towards going
towards those places that you don't want
to go and then relaxing right there
relaxing in those places and you're
right I probably had a tense face my
shoulders were a little relaxed though
but my legs were relaxed but that's not
like it's really it was really it's the
face like Body Connection to the vagina
that really made all the difference once
I went to my next verse going wait the
point of it is to go to the places where
you feel it the most when you're saying
the highest part of your wave or
contraction sensation and then relax
right there instead of trying to hide
from it right you know that that if you
can imagine you know your
um your surges like this this you know
rise in intensity that Peak for me is so
exciting because that Peak means that's
when your cervix is going to be dilating
the most that's when your contraction is
really pulling and helping to dilate so
you know at that point that's like yes
you know I'm at the top now I'm at the
top let me lean into this and then yes
you're leaning into it leaning into it
and you know that Peak only should last
around 10 to 20 seconds you know if you
really feel it feel that rise that 10 to
20 seconds and then you can let it go
you can let it go and that's one down
you know know and and and you're right I
think when you said about
um it didn't compute you know with you
it didn't sort of register this is the
thing with hypnobirthing and with you
know how childbirth is educated how
maybe someone else talks about
childbirth or teaches hypnobirthing is
not going to resonate the same to
someone as maybe the way I teach it and
this is why you have to find something
that resonates with you you know some
people
um don't you know don't fight I mean I
don't know this but maybe some people
don't like you know the sort of visual
side and they want more in depth you
know but then other people come to me
and they go oh I've done Hitler birthing
before and I didn't really get on with
it then they've done my hypnobirthing
they're like oh my God this is insane
because it resonates with them so it has
to work for you otherwise there's no
point don't go into a hypnobirthing
class if it's not going to resonate with
you because it won't stay in your head
yeah exactly because it really has to
tap into your subconscious and really
make sense and for me it was like I
thought I was doing all the right things
by relaxing but it really I was missing
a mark and it was until my Midwife came
in after like hours so many hours of
just staying at like that early stage
but feeling like it was just so long and
dragged out she's like Ellen relax your
birthing muscles right there that's
where you have to relax or you're never
going to progress because like you said
at the top it if we resist that contract
that
um contraction and that that Peak then
that's making it harder for it to
actually open but if you lean into it
then it opens easier and then you'll
your labor will be quicker and then it
actually starts to feel better when you
do that too because you're not at war
with your body 100 100 and this is it
when it when it's when it feels right in
your brain and when you're able to work
with the body it then becomes a
completely different feeling you know
yeah it feels intense but it doesn't
feel
like a scary kind of pain it feels more
like this intense you know
powerful feeling that you can work with
and you know you can do it and yeah
that's it's incredible I can't we can
even relate that to sex I know it's
you're gonna have an amazing birthday I
mean you've been teaching This and like
you're helping so many women with this
information that it's like way in your
subconscious like you know it to be true
no exactly exactly I I'm yeah I'm really
excited I can't wait for the
contractions
they are my favorite things
it's amazing so can you talk about also
the kiko position is that how you talk
how you say it yeah so Kiko k-i-c-o so
it's the abbreviation uh that I coined a
few years ago it stands for knees in
carves out
so so basically how this works is
if you can imagine the the pelvis say
this is the pelvis okay so when we are
near to giving birth our babies drop
into the pelvis so at the start of our
labor we may want to have our legs open
which opens the pelvic Inlet okay but
then as we progress through Labor and
our baby's dropping down to the pelvis a
lot of the time
then women are told open your legs
really wide open your legs really wide
but do you see how by doing that I'm
closing off this space at the bottom
so when they get to the pushing stage
and women are being told put your legs
put your legs knees really far out
you're actually closing this space when
actually if you brought your knees in
you're actually
bringing more space into the pelvic
Outlet which gives the baby
space to be able to move and turn and
come down and into the world now by no
means should everyone be doing this
because I am a complete advocate for
listening to your body and going into
positions that feel good for you however
giving birth on your back with your legs
wide open is really not ideal for you or
for your baby and it actually restricts
that movement in the pelvis
so many people actually
without even knowing bring their knees
want to bring their knees inwards it's
sometimes just a thing that people you
know people do in birth just naturally
and even animals do it there's some
great pictures of giraffes uh and
elephants giving birth with their knees
in
it's amazing because naturally that's
what they want to do and that's what
Kiko is all about so it's about opening
up the space in the pelvic Outlet to
give space for your baby to be able to
rotate and come out into the world
okay so I need to tell you how exciting
this is for me because this is the first
thing I I went my a friend of mine named
Yadi was telling me about your page and
that's how I found you like I forget
maybe eight months ago and I was
scrolling through your page and then I
saw this thing about the kiko position
and it was like a light bulb went off
for me because in every single birth I
kid you not what you just said I have
this as I'm pushing I have this
inclination like my knees go in and and
I'm leaning back normally I'm like in
the tub leaning back that's just how I
end up in the position and my knees go
in and it's always like open open so we
can like see the baby but I just I don't
know why but as I start like breathing
the baby out my knees just keep going in
and it's so hard to even get it open
because my body doesn't want to do that
and I'm like why am I doing that like
why does my body do that when I want the
baby to come out like why am I closing
my legs but the way that you explain
that it was like a light bulb went on
for me so I told my Midwife about it
she's like oh my God gosh yeah that
makes so much sense she had never heard
of that and I had never heard anybody in
all my years of talking about birth ever
talk about that but it makes complete
sense when you show the diaphragm or the
diagram I mean of what it looks like
um like the female the bones and the
body so then
right so my question is then if you're
leaning back like would it be better
then because then if I'm leaning back in
the tub and my legs are naturally
closing isn't that a little bit harder
to maybe like grab the baby feet like
feel the baby should I be trying to move
into a position where I'm on all fours
because you showed those three different
Kiko options where you can lean forward
and I guess I could try to do that but I
really like the idea of being able to
like pull the baby up instead of like
somebody else grabbing it from behind my
butt you know yeah so does it work the
same way even if I'm leaning on a tub
backwards 100 so so when you're in a tub
when you're actually in water there is
no restrictions on the back of your
pelvis your tailbone because what
actually happens is that when baby's
coming down the pelvis once the pelvic
Outlet wants to open but then also the
sacrum the back of the tailbone of the
pelvis wants to move outwards you see so
you're creating optimal space this is
why lying straight on your back
restricts this this tailbone from moving
you know it's really difficult for the
pelvis to open
what you're doing or what you wanted to
do or what you were doing
unintentionally by bringing your knees
in is completely natural completely you
know instinctive and that was your
body's way of of helping to open up that
space I just find it it's so beautiful
so beautiful because your body
instinctively was doing that but in
society in our minds we're going oh why
why is this yeah oh I open the leg yeah
why is this happening and then mid you
know midwives or
um whoever is it's caring for you open
your legs open your legs but actually
this is because in medical school they
they don't learn about the biomechanics
of the pelvis that's not something they
learn it it's it's unfortunately you
know a lot of it is medicalized and
there's not enough probably about you
know the physiology of birth and how the
pelvis works because if there was we'd
probably be getting you know most of the
time people to actually bring their
knees inwards you know if we are are
coaching that part of birth so for you
leaning back in the tub that is
absolutely fine bringing your knees and
that's fine you will
you will catch your baby
even if your knees are in
when your baby's coming you will catch
your baby you know you'll know as soon
as it yeah exactly exactly true and
there's no there's not even any Rush
Ellen to to get get the baby out the
water you know that gentle transition
um is is absolutely fine you know
there's no there's no real rush to do
that and taking that you know birth
pause
um that that so many do that is
completely fine but yeah you'll find a
lot of people ask the same thing they're
like yeah but if I do that I can't get
you will yeah you will yeah because as
soon as the baby is expelled as soon as
you feel the baby's being expelled from
your vagina you know you you are
automatically there your knees are
already out the way
yes you know so do you feel like it's
more optimal though to lean forward with
that like bear crawl type of look is it
a little bit easier even that way within
that position it would always be most
optimal leaning forward or upright only
because then you're working with gravity
if you can imagine
um If you're sort of laying this laying
down or laying back or or in that sort
of
leading position your baby when it when
the baby comes out they have to actually
go up like this up and out the vagina if
you are more in an upright position
they're going down with the gravity
so that's the only reason I think I
yeah no keep going that's the only
reason why but ultimately it's it's
whatever feels instinctively right to do
at that time because your body knows
better than any
whatever people say around you whatever
I've said or whatever you know whatever
you know the Midwife or doctor said your
body knows the best position to be in at
that time for your baby so it has to be
it has to be comfortable for you
right I think I always instinctively
like I start on all fours but then as
I'm like as that really pushing
inclination surge is happening and I'm
trying to slow it down I try I go back
because I'm like trying to breathe the
baby up so it doesn't come out so hard
you know the way that it's like that
soft gentle breathing out as opposed to
pushing out
yeah so that's why I end up doing that
but I'm so excited to take that
information into my next birth it's
gonna be amazing I can't wait I can't
wait to hear about it it's gonna be so
really fast as well I'll tell yeah I'll
tell you how it goes I know because it
is it is the you know fast even all of
mine have been like under 30 to 40
minutes but I wonder how much easier it
will be with keeping that natural
intuition and close close the legs how
it'll go from then so I'll update you
guys
so then is this position then when you
speak about it mainly just for when you
reach full dilation and you're breathing
baby out or is it also during labor
positions so if you can uh a lot of
people use it use it and instinctively
go into it for the pushing push I say
pushing with inverted commas because I
hate that the force pushing so yeah
context yeah
um but a lot of people do use it in that
place but at the the later stages of of
your labor when your baby is at the
bottom of the pelvis okay if you um
if you if your Midwife did an exam for
example some people have them some
people don't and they told you you know
your baby's station is is sort of down
here which is Plus
zero plus one two three four five okay
which is medical a lot of people don't
talk about it but anything below that
point anything later on in labor then
that is a good good position to use I've
had women use it for back to back labor
they've actually found it really helpful
maybe because it opens up the spacing
and takes the pressure off the nerves on
the back
um others have used it for later on in
labor for breech babies as well so again
it has to be instinctive it shouldn't be
a case of oh what do I do now let me go
into this position no just go with your
body your you want to allow your baby to
come into the pelvis really connect with
your baby feel you where your baby is
and do what your body wants to do you
know so yeah Kiko is for later later
stages of labor and for the pushing
breathing baby out stage yes perfect so
we have to recap that we basically have
the focusing on the oxytocin when it
comes to your labor and equating sex and
birth and how even kissing hugging
Sensational sensual experiences is
associated with having a more
pleasurable birth then you talked about
the floppy face floppy Fanny and
relaxing down there relaxing your face
and your vagina and then there's the
kiko position like all three of those
things I'm seeing in your testimonies of
that helping people so much in their
birth so much so and you know what a
floppy face floppy funny practice that
while she goes to the toilet if you need
to go for a number two and you're
struggling try that technique whilst
you're doing that and also if you're
being intimate with your partner
practice it then when you're having sex
like and feel how intense and insane
your orgasm is
because you can really notice the
difference if you allow your face I mean
you might look a bit you might feel a
bit silly because you know but if you
just completely let go
then you will really notice the
difference in how that feels and it's
just a perfect reminder of how you can
Implement that into birth
that's great advice and this also makes
me think of if you're listening to this
and you're pregnant you don't have a
partner like you can be intimate with
yourself to help get you to that place
as well so I want to get into my next
question about I saw you do a post about
your reasons why you should or shouldn't
have an epidural can you kind of explain
the pros and cons and the different
experiences or examples when one should
or shouldn't in their birth yeah for
sure so the re so first and foremost the
decision is ultimately yours no matter
what
um but I always say to people the
decisions shouldn't be based around fear
it should be based around really
informed
um choice and understanding of the body
so someone who
um May can be considering an epidural on
where an epidural might be really
helpful is someone who has been laboring
for an extremely long time they're very
tired they're
um not getting along very well what
happens when you have an epidural at
this time is it gives your body the much
needed rest that you need for your body
to build up that energy and and birth
your baby okay that is a really good
example of where an epidural may be
helpful
um there's also other times for example
if you know some people do find it
extremely overwhelming they find it you
know spiritually physically emotionally
just everything's just too much for them
and when that is the case
and you know you're never going to
progress with that with that mind and
with that feeling of of of of fear
um and this is where it would be
extremely helpful and also that leading
on to my other point is being very tense
again if you're completely tense you
cannot let it go and some people can't
some people
are so tense
that they're even if you try and help
them relax they just it they just can't
it's just it's too much and at that
point that's not going to be helpful for
the body or for the baby so an epidural
might be a a good answer to that but the
thing is with epidurals is you don't
have to just go in and have an epidural
and all of a sudden you can't move your
legs which is what a lot of people think
um you can have a walking epidural you
can control how much of the epidural
you're having so you can still feel
certain things
um and even if you do have an epidural
and I'll go on to the reasons it gates
in a second even if you do have an
epidural you can still Implement things
like Kiko from a side lying position
with help from your Midwife so there are
ways around it doesn't mean if you have
an epidural that's it you know
um you can't do anything you can't move
there are lots of options for that so
that's important for people to remember
that if they do there are there are
options now reasons against
um
reasons against an epidural would be
first of all they are not always
successful
and people don't realize this but they
don't always work for some people
um so you can imagine you really really
want it and then it doesn't work I mean
that's going to be even worse a
situation
um but sometimes it doesn't work it has
an effect on your your body's natural
hormones so it has an effect on your
oxytocin
um unfortunately can lead to other
interventions because if if you are if
you an epidural primarily is blocking
the sensations and the nerves and the
connection and the the the the talking
that's happening between the bottom of
your body and your brain
so
if there's a break in that connection of
blocking that connection your your body
can't talk to your brain your brain
can't talk to your body in the the
hormones can't flow properly so then you
may need to introduce things like
um uh centosinone or pitocin uh known In
America which is the artificial hormone
artificial oxytocin hormone drip and
other types of interventions which you
know can then cause
um can then sort of lead on to other
interventions Like Instrumental birth
and emergency C-sections
and this is why it's really important to
know the pros and the cons because I'm
not saying that if you have an epidural
all those things will happen to you
because that's not the case but
statistically this is what it looks like
if you were to have it
um it's also advised not to have an
epidural later on too late in your labor
because it can have an effect on the
baby so baby may come out quite drowsy
it might take them longer to latch to
the breast
um and things like that so it is really
important to be aware of but at the same
time sometimes it is needed and
sometimes it is extremely helpful for
those who do need it
that's really helpful thank you for
sharing that so I think it's like at the
end of the day it comes down to your
informed choice and be able to hear the
pros and cons to both things and each
situation is different every woman is
different and so it just depends and
when you said about that that part about
how some women can't
um you know to relax I A lot of times it
it really depends on like the state of
their emotion their trauma that maybe
there are some past traumas result like
unresolved and if that if they wanted
and desired a labor without an epidural
they might go into their next pregnancy
if they get pregnant again being and
wanting to kind of resolve and heal some
of those traumas through different
modalities that um help them that might
really shift the way that they feel
going into the next Labor yeah 100 you
know some people really they love
they're like oh I'm so glad I had the
epidural or those who have gone through
a whole labored whole you know
completely naturally to a point where
they've gone no I just need it I'm
taught too tired now and you know know
that's okay it's all about informed
choice this is all about pro-choice like
it just has to be your decision and it
has to be an informed decision and that
way
however however the outcome is as long
as you've made those informed choices
along the way it's always going to feel
you know uh positive to you because
you've helped make those decisions it's
not being taken out of your control
yeah it'll be empowering rather than
disempowering right totally okay so my
next question is what advice do you have
a woman going into the first half the
beginning stages of their labor
I I love to talk about this because
so a lot of the time as soon as
contractions start people tend to go
oh my God
and they'll they'll start looking around
for things that they possibly need to to
do uh you know or we need to call
somebody but actually when you first
start to feel those those
um those surges which are manageable
at the start of your labor this is a
perfect time to celebrate
and it's the perfect time to really
party uh I like to say party through the
first stage of your labor and get the
music on that you love you know dance
move all this movement and dancing and
mixed with oxytocin is is gold dust it
is it is setting you up
for a really incredible birth experience
because not only dancing in the movement
statistically that has shown so many
good results it's it's shown you know
especially dancing in the first stage of
Labor has shown to increase dilation
it's it's shown to
um be linked to Shorter labors you know
and this is all because not only are you
moving helping baby move down gravity
and also moving during contractions is
so so good for managing how it feels
but then on top of that listening to
music that makes you feel really really
good or that music where you go oh my
God this reminds me of like five years
ago when I went to that holiday
um or I you know we did this or that is
gonna really spark memories and really
really feel good feelings inside your
brain which then helps with oxytocin
helps with endorphins so first stage of
Labor celebration time get the music on
be with your partner you know or whoever
makes you feel good dance move enjoy you
know but at the same time if that
doesn't feel good for you if you are at
the first stage of Labor and all you
want to do is sleep
sleep
it's all about listening to your body
you know it's all about listening to
your body but for those who do feel like
they are awake and they want to do
something dance dance and party first
stage of Labor
I love that it's so true especially for
a first time laborers
um it can be tempting to be like first
contraction quick call the doctor Call
the Midwife get everything instead like
it's a little bit hyper but um it's
really helpful I think to take both what
you said about if you're going into
labor in the middle of the night just
try to sleep because you want to have
the energy for the next day if your
active labor actually doesn't really
start until maybe the next night and if
you haven't slept all night the night
before you know that's gonna kind of be
at a disadvantage for you once you go
into that labor because you want to have
energy once it gets more intense but
then during the day the party aspect of
just making it beautiful and flow
filling I feel like is connected to the
oxytocin aspect that you're talking
about about intimacy and just love and
calm safe secure dancing is a part of
that and then I also think a third
component that can be really helpful too
is just um try not try to just keep
going about your day you know because if
you're like stop it's labor time it
might feel like your labor is longer
than it actually is and it might feel a
little defeating if by the next evening
you're like why isn't the baby here yet
when really if that whole first day
you're just going about your day you
don't even have to tell anyone you know
as long as you can talk through the
contractions and the waves like just
keep going about your day because that's
gonna for one help move it along too
because you're moving about along with
like dancing and then on top of it if
your labor is going to feel a lot
shorter exactly exactly if if you know
if you feel things coming on and you can
just get on with your day 100 if it's in
the middle of the night you can sleep
sleep you know like it's such good
advice and then when things do get
regular when things start to get to get
more regular and a little bit more
intense then you know you can introduce
the dance you can go right okay but time
pressures are a big thing when we put
time pressures on ourselves and I always
say to people take down your clock
if you have a clock on the wall take it
down you know don't don't keep looking
at times on your phone like you need to
really get into this whole losing the
track of time because time can really be
the thing that slows labor down and
causes these sort of panics
um along the way
right so true I so agree with that it's
such helpful information that a lot of
people just don't even talk about and
also part of it is from the movies that
we see like first contract and let's go
get to the hospital yeah exactly and
it's like the the break you know water's
breaking like that only happens to 10 of
women before Labor and even at that
point labor may not start straight away
which is also okay which is also a
variation of normal so you know what we
see on TV is like what is breaking you
know in the middle of the supermarket
and everyone's ah and it's you know it's
not like that it doesn't have to be like
that yeah you know it's right it's it's
not
right it's uh I'm glad you brought up
Waters breaking though because uh it is
advised that to not be intimate or to
not have sex if your water has already
broken and that is really helpful
information
but yes it's a small percent it is it is
so yeah so obviously when your Waters we
you know before before water's breaking
there's a 0.5 of infection right when
our Waters break it goes up to one
percent so it's not a massive amount but
then when you start for example uh yeah
if you were to have sex
um it can increase but then more so if
you're having vaginal examinations and
also other interventions that can
increase the risk of infection once your
Waters have gone
um so this is why again this is another
thing to be really informed about
because a lot of the time we think oh my
God my Waters have gone I need to get
into the hospital right now no your body
just might need a little bit of time and
for those who whose Waters haven't broke
they may break during labor they may not
break it all that is also a variation of
normal and that is also okay for your
baby to be born on call you know like
inside the sack
it's not it's fine
yeah totally okay so can I want to talk
a little bit more about the topic of um
no forced pushing can you explain a
little bit about that because that is
kind of the standard like when you you
feel the urge to push or your or let's
say you have an epidural and you're told
push you know there's a big stigma
around it and I know with my first birth
um I ignored the advice of my Midwife
because my labor was so long that once I
got to that really extreme urge to push
something I basically had never felt
before in my life obviously
um she's telling me to slow down breathe
like don't push like that type of thing
and I just I ignored her because I was
like I just want to get this baby out as
fast as I can I'm so over this basically
is what I felt
um when really pushing wasn't actually
necessarily going to make the baby come
out any faster and I only caused a
disservice to myself because then I did
tear and it was minor it was only like a
few stitches but once I went into my
other my next labors my last three
labors I took the advice of the No Force
pushing and the breathing baby up and
the gentle and I have I did not tear
sense so let's get into that what's your
best advice to avoid tearing all that I
I love this one because sometimes it
causes you know quite a bit of
controversy controversy and and
conversations because people can't
understand like how you can breathe your
baby out and you know when I'm when I'm
saying that and I'll explain a bit more
about the technique in a minute I'm not
saying just breathe like this you know
you know we we are going to do a bit of
work but the forced pushing so the the
gritty teeth and aren't kind of pushing
that you often see it on the television
and that people often talk about and
still happens now in hospitals is
extremely outdated you know it it's it's
from it's from so that advice is from so
so long ago it was like featured in
1920s Vogue magazine you know about the
best way to push your baby out using
gritted teeth and force pushing but
actually since then they found that this
can be really dangerous for you and for
your baby because you're really
restricting the oxygen to your baby but
also like you say when that when we're
forcing against something that's you
know not you know it's very tight and
not able to stretch and open you know we
are going to increase our chances of
tearing or needing instrumental
um instrumental you know birth and other
interventions
so breathing your baby out is really
about working with those contractions so
they're very backwards feeling because
you've gone through this whole you know
first you know first uh stage of Labor
with these you know surges feeling a
certain way then all of a sudden they
sort of do a backflip and you're you're
you can't you know help but feel this
bearing down and this is where you
really want to work with that you know
when you when you feel that rise to and
fall to Bear down this is where you
really want to take that breath
and just take that breath down through
the body and you you're using that
breath to help push gently on your
uterus some people don't even have to do
that you know because just by doing that
motion and just by leaning into it your
body naturally your your uterus is doing
most of the work so you don't tend to
have to put a lot of of anything into it
but it's about keeping that face soft
surrendering into it and using that
breath to push down the body
what's really important about this is
sometimes you will have pauses in
between and those pauses are really
important they're not you know oh oh no
like you know I need to keep pushing no
those pauses are made to be there
they're helping your perineum stretch
they're helping you know your body to
just gain that bit of energy it needs
again
there's so many reasons for that and
this is why it's important at this point
to go right okay I'm just going to
really just be in control of this
situation now and I'm going to really
work with my body take the energy I need
to take during those pauses and then
work with your body again and breathe
your baby out so many people
come to me and say oh my God I literally
breathe my baby out I can't believe it I
never thought it was actually possible I
thought you know you had to push but you
don't
and some people don't want to do
absolutely nothing at all because the
fetal ejection reflex of the uterus
literally just expels your baby you know
when your baby's ready to come your
baby's ready to come and you cannot do
anything no yeah anything about it right
so yeah I I I get really frustrated when
I hear
you know people are I was I was told I
was forced to to Really push hard and
Force and and it makes me really sad
especially because some of these people
you know really didn't want to do that
but they felt really coerced into doing
that
um and this is why you know preparation
is important and having the conversation
with your provider and being able to
Advocate you know which is not always
possible when you're in I mean when
you're in the birth world in the
birthstone and you're having a baby
you're extremely vulnerable you know but
if you can take yourself and just bring
yourself back to that moment and work
with your body it will work wonders and
you're like like you said you didn't you
didn't tear and that won't be the case
for everyone but you're highly reducing
your risk of tearing by allowing your
your face to be soft that floppy face
sloppy Fanny and breathing your baby out
rather than that forced pushing
yeah and a lot of times that that Force
pushing does feel like an intuition like
it's like it feels like like you want to
push like for me it's like I don't have
any desire to push until baby is coming
all of a sudden it's like this
irresistible oh I have to like you want
to push yeah and so what my Midwife
recommended to me in my second birth
because she's like this wonderful
Midwife that's been she's retired now
she's like in her 80s now but or how
actually I don't know her exact age now
but she's she's definitely retired and
she practiced in um certain parts of
Africa at one point and learned from all
different types of amazing she was
incredible
um but she told me to breathe my baby up
to do like the counter into of my
intuition because I had such a strong
desire to push like I wanted to push
that's what my body that's what I wanted
to do but in order to help lessen the
likelihood of tearing and to go slower
so that your body can stretch as the
head is coming out she said breathe up
and it sounds so weird and I looked at
her like she was crazy at first but I
did it and it was amazing it was an
amazing way for me to counter that the
energy to push really hard yes so I was
so I breed up basically with this
breathing up so that I wasn't doing that
pushing that I wanted to do and that
helped me so much so but it was a form
of breath getting that baby out but it
was just a way to get it was a way to
help me to actually Channel it as
opposed to go into what I wanted to do
which was actually push super hard
do you know what 100 and it makes so it
makes so much sense it makes so much
sense because you're countering that
energy and that's perfect and again if
that if that works for you that's
fantastic and I I actually love that I I
love that because I know the way I've
explained it
I've I've seen that and I talk about it
but not in that way so I really really
like the way you've spoken about that
um yeah but it's so true because you do
get this unbearable urge to to push down
and people you can't help it's just
happening and this is how you really
need to work with that energy and by
breathing sort of breathing up to then
release and breathe down is a beautiful
way of doing it yeah beautiful way yeah
because it basically helps slow it but
it actually you would think oh that
means it's going to take longer for the
baby to come out but it didn't at all it
just wasn't it actually was faster like
a lot faster to come out but it was just
a more gentle transition where I wasn't
pushing hard on my body I wasn't forcing
that baby's head down it was going a
little bit lighter and then it came out
like just like more gentle right because
you're redirecting that energy you know
that energy of uh you're you're bringing
it up you're redirecting the energy you
know and then it's it's it's actually
really good because then you sort of you
know naturally be bear down in a more
controlled way so yeah that's beautiful
yeah and then she did at the very end
she she checked and she's like okay the
cord is wrapped around the neck now you
need to actually push so then then that
last one that I that I did that natural
urge to just like grunt it out
um and then baby came right out after
that so that was amazing do you know
what it's about you've just touched on
grunting there noises is such a
wonderful tool especially during that
stage of Labor don't be scared to use
low vibrational noises
um it's really helpful it's another way
to use that energy what you was just
saying about that yeah unbearable urge
um actually using noise as a way to
direct that energy is a really useful
tool as well
mm-hmm and I think yeah totally and then
I also think going back to that forced
pushing thing you were saying a lot of
times it seems to happen the most if
someone has had an epidural and they
can't feel their body so they don't know
their body signals and then they're kind
of told push really hard here as opposed
to the breathing baby out techniques
which would be a lot more helpful
exactly exactly and you know what you
can still you can still be able to sort
of take aspects from that even if you've
had an epidural so just remember to keep
your face really soft so when you are
sort of using your breath to to push
down to Bear down you can still do the
same technique you can still you know
apply that pressure but keep your face
really soft and it will ultimately
reduce you know the the chances of
tearing even with an aperture or yeah
because if you can't feel your body and
so they have to tell you when the waves
are coming essentially right right and
then at that point when they're saying
push you could use that push signal to
actually breathe baby out 100.
yeah at those times okay this has been
such a fun conversation I have one more
question for you
um but I just love all these different
aspects about having an empowered birth
experience so can you just share your
final takeaway for anyone listening on
how to have an empowered birth
experience for sure so it's really
important for people to remember that
this is your birth this is your birth
okay this isn't this is nobody else's
story this is nobody else's you know
interest this this is all about you and
for you and no matter what birth you're
having you can influence it it's really
you know you have to be in the right
frame of mind but if you really truly
want to experience birth in
an enjoyable way
start now and that could it doesn't
matter where you are on your journey
maybe you're you know in your third
trimester maybe you're you're maybe
you're listening to this on your due
date it's okay it's not too late it's
never too late to really dig within it
it would dig deep within ourselves find
that inner power just through knowledge
education educate yourselves and you
know find that knowledge and find that
power once you find yourself doing this
you honestly you open your eyes and you
become this this ball of confidence and
you go into labor feeling really good
about what's going to happen because you
understand just like anything you're not
going to jump out of an airplane without
doing the preparation first
you know you're not going to you're
going to go you're going to do the
preparation you're going to understand
what's happening then you're going to
jump out and you're going to feel good
like you know what you've got to do it's
the same with birth so please I urge
everyone to
get the get the confidence first and
foremost to get yourself educated and
just watch yourself grow watch that
power burn inside of you it's like a
fire and just feel really amazing about
birth
follow pages and accounts that make you
feel good not just mine I mean like in
general and delete and mute anything
that makes you feel like crap
hmm yeah
yes the energy protecting your energy in
such a vulnerable and sensitive time for
sure
yes oh my gosh this is amazing thank you
so much I feel so pumped going into my
fifth birth now I mean I just love birth
so much it just gets me so excited it's
probably my one of my favorite things to
talk about for sure oh it's been so
amazing and I just love that you're so
close as well I feel like this is such a
good time to be having a conversation
like I just love it and you're making me
excited and I've got a while to go yeah
oh but I'm so excited for you too like
you're just gonna have such an amazing
birth and I can't wait to see it unfold
thank you okay well I think we'll end it
here thank you so much everyone for
listening and we'll see you next episode
[Music]